يروى انا اداء منتخب الكاميرون للاستثنائي
في مونديال ايطاليا عام 90 كان مرتبط
بصوره مباشره بحديقه حيوانات ما حدث ان
لاعبي الكاميرون طلب تغيير محل اقامتهم
الذي اختاره مسؤول بعثتهم الى اخر يقع
بجانب حديقه حيوانات تعمل بنمط السفاري اي
ان الحيوانات الموجوده بداخلها تكون طريقه
قرر اللاعبون مطلبهم بان وجودهم قرب
الاسود والزرافات وحيوانات افريقيه اخرى
سيشعرهم بانهم اكثر قربا من وطنهم
معايداتهم وفق المسؤولون على طلب اللاعبين
الذين قضوا معظم وقت فراغهم في حديقه
الحيوانات وبرر المستوى المدهش الذي قدمه
لاعبوا الكاميرون سببت تغيير المكان واثبت
ان روح اللاعب تتغذى بشيء اكثر اهميه من
التدريبات واشرطه الفيديو